I've spent the past several days solving
some of hogwart's legacy's darkest
Secrets take for example this treasure
Vault just north of clag more castle
inside you'll find a cloaked figure
crumpled on the ground as you approach
you may notice the Moss overtaking the
body but it's the note beside this
figure a note containing just one word
that will send a chill down your
spine there are actually 11 characters
similar to this one Wizards and witches
who met an untimely end in their
Ventures across the Scottish Highlands
in this video I'll reveal all the
locations as well as any related notes
or letters left behind and I'll also
attempt to piece together exactly how
these characters died rello the official
Hogwarts Legacy Channel actually put out
this challenge to us fans months ago as
an opportunity for exploration and
Discovery there are 11 NPCs in the open
world who each died in mysterious ways
with notes that tell each of their
unique stories see if you can find them
all surprisingly as I was researching
for this video I found no comprehensive
list there were bits and pieces here and
there especially in the early days of
the game as fans stumbled across these
NPCs usually in shock at what they found
perhaps even more surprisingly though
this 11 does not include the tragic fate
of TOS the house elf nor does it count
the grizzly demise of the spider
breeding Mary Portman no we're talking
11 NPCs unrelated to major or even minor
story quest lines and even with nearly
200 hours of Total play time in Legacy I
had personally missed quite a few of
these so here are the stories of 11
witches and wizards whose tragic Fates
show a much darker side of the Wizarding
World in the hamlet of krack Croft you
can find a letter on the notice board
just outside of town it's labeled as the
crack coft love letter in your inventory
with a date of September 21st 1871 in
the letter A Man by the name of William
laments being away from his darling
Susan he lets her know he plans to be in
London for at least 3 more months but
hopes to be home for Christmas he's also
quite fond of her mother's trial Tarts
tragically William and Susan's story
does not end with a happily ever after
to discover William's fate you'll need
to travel west of Kenbridge where you'll
come to an inconspicuous cave there's a
Whirlpool at the end of the path and
Diving through this pool leads you to a
body William's body his body rests in
the mud with his travel supplies nearby
beside him is the final entry in a diary
which gives us a bit more context into
how he may have died my beloved the Moon
is not yet full yet such is my family's
fear that they have sent me away
prematurely I am frightened as a wolf I
am powerful but before the Moon is round
I am merely human Merlin knows what
beasts I may encounter in my present
form it does no good to dwell upon it I
hope I last this night and will be in
your arms before long William with
hogwart's Legacy taking place in the
late 1800s William would have had little
hope for a cure the wolfbane potion
which only helps to relieve the symptoms
of lycanthropy wasn't invented until
sometime after the 1970s by democles BBY
who happened to be a student of horse
slug horn at Hogwarts while Williams
body doesn't contain any visible wounds
we can see his clothes have been ripped
and torn perhaps he was attacked by one
of the many beasts he feared in his
diary or maybe he could never bring
himself to leave the cave and died of
thirst or starvation either way it's
clear he and Susan never got the future
that they were hoping for one of the
most fearsome creatures in all of the
Wizarding World would have to be the
Basilisk breeding them would actually
land you a lifelong sentence and as
command just so happens a significant
portion of the plot in Hogwarts Legacy
deals heavily with poaching activities
and the illegal breeding of certain
unauthorized creatures such as
acromantula and yes even basilisks if
you stop by the daily profit stand in
hogsmead you may come across the story
about a Cornish wizard who was arrested
for breeding basilisks he he pleaded
ignorance and claimed that his chicken
CS were Simply Irresistible to toads and
while I don't think it's the same wizard
mentioned in this Prophet article you
actually can find the body of an illegal
breeder and one that the ministry
certainly had on their radar start by
fast traveling to the tower tunnel Flo
flamee located at the most Southeastern
point of maren weam Lake from there
start making your way back down the
mountain until you spot an area blocked
by the devil snare Roots cast lumos and
make her way through to find our second
victim as well as a couple of chickens
and two empty cages nearby this letter
is from the ministry of magic and is
giving the individual advanced notice
they'll soon be inspecting his chicken
cop for any toads on the premises you
see in the World of Harry Potter
basilisks are created by hatching
chicken eggs beneath a toad once the
Basilisk hatches they're incredibly
dangerous creatures looking indirectly
into their eyes results in petrification
a frozen state that can only be cured
with a mandric restorative draft looking
directly into the eyes of a basilisk
however results in instant an death
unless you're a ghost so it would seem
this illegal breeder actually succeeded
in hatching a basilisk and yet he didn't
seem to take the proper precautions to
avoid its deadly gaze whereas our last
victim suffered the consequences of
trying to perform a dangerous illegal
activity for profit our next case is one
who appears to have had only the best
intentions in mind this tale begins at
the West Hogwarts Valley flu flame head
north from there flying above the cliffs
until you come across a campsite with a
wagon outside here you'll find not one
but two dead bodies the first one is
concealed whereas the second one is just
beside the wagon surrounding the bodies
are books a few plants potions and a
number of other healing items the note
here indicates the witch before us was
actually a Healer attempting to cure a
patient from a textbook case of dragon
pox as noted by the typical symptoms
such as Pock marked skin sneezing Sparks
and a rash between the toes I have
prescribed a second dose of the gors
Cure but it may not be sufficient as
such I have f further prescribed an
Elixir to induce Euphoria to ease the
patient's probable passing must sanitize
my equipment highly contagious but even
with the knowledge of the incredible
risk of being around the disease and
knowing how important it was to sanitize
her equipment it appears she too
contracted the disease and died only a
few feet away from the very person she'd
been trying to save the next body
belongs to a poacher by the name of
Smithy this location is accessed from
within a poppy seding mission called
poached egg as the two of you set out to
return an egg belonging to a hiyan black
dragon you'll see her fly overhead
shortly after you pass directly under
her you'll come across a large tree
branch in your path jump over it take
out the mongrels but then don't be too
quick to leave the area straight ahead
and just to the left of the wooden steps
you'll find Smithy search him to find a
letter from his poacher friend Angus
Angus and his traveling companion Violet
have moved away from the fighting ring
Venture and are instead dealing an
acromantulas the letter seems to end
indicate there had been some form of
previous correspondence between them as
Angus seems to think Smithy was planning
to join them as for a cause of death
perhaps he was taken out by the very
dragon that Poppy and our main character
have saved but given the state of his
clothes and the lack of any Scorch or
burn marks my guess as Smithy superiors
learned of his plans to leave and then
decided he was just another loose end
for their dragon fighting ring roughly
halfway between the central Hogwarts
Valley and a andure flu Flames you'll
find a wooded area teaming with Fighters
just off the path is our next victim
wand still in hand he carries a letter
of warning from one Gerald olivander it
would appear the unnamed customer had
previously written to olivander about
whether or not he should continue using
his late ants wand of course longtime
fans of the series know the importance
of the wand choosing the wizard this
proves especially important in the
series as Harry has to navigate through
a significant portion of the final book
without access to his own wand olivander
seems particularly concerned about this
case in hogwart's Legacy because it
involves a wand made from acacia wood
which he describes as being particularly
temperamental given the area where we
find this respected customer I'm left to
believe he drew the wand and attempted
to fight off the oncoming spiders
instead of protecting him however the
wand backfired and CA him his
life so far these dark Mysteries have
mainly consisted of accidents or
dangerous activities taken too far but
case number six is one of straight up
murder a wizard named Hubert can be
found near a waterfall just west of the
poir castle flu flame we find a door
completely detached from its hinge
laying near the front of a small Stone
shelter cauldron sits at the center with
a large Scorch Mark extending out from
it Hubert's body is behind the cauldron
and on him is a letter to his friend
deah in it he tells her about a series
of pranks that he's recently been the
victim of they started out small enough
biting door knobs and pixies in his
closet but after an unexpected Port key
sent him to Cumbria Hubert began to fear
the pranks had a more Sinister intent as
such he wrote to the ministry with hopes
they could inspect his house for jinxes
now unfortunately for Hubert this
inspection could actually take several
days which means he needed a place to
stay I shall be displaced for a while
may I stay with you it will be just me
and my trusty cauldron Hubert sadly for
Hubert the very cauldron he mentions has
been jinxed presumably by the Sinister
prankster this of course results in the
explosion and one that happens to be
strong enough to blow the door off its
hinges as well as leave this large burn
mark as I can find no other body in the
area it would seem that Hubert never
made it to his friend Leah fortunate for
her of all the deaths we've investigated
so far this one may have the most
mysterious cause of death and it's not
only one body we find but three if you
fly south from the West Manor Cape flu
flame you'll pass a series of cracky
faed Cliffs at first it may not appear
as if there's anywhere to land but
continue along the southwest side and
you will eventually come to a small boat
and a campsite along the shore there are
two skeletal remains here next to the
fire and a third closer to the boat and
speaking of the boat it doesn't appear
to have had a smooth Journey a few
wooden boards have washed a Shore
separate from it and it also looks like
there may have been some sort of crash
or explosion here the most mysterious
part of the scene though has to be the
shape of these large Scorch marks
they're the ones over by the third body
and is it just me or does this actually
look like the Grim there's also a diary
entry nearby that only leaves us with
more questions the writings are clearly
that of a witch or wizard fearing for
their life after multiple perceived
sightings of the Grim a well-known Omen
of death in The Wizarding World the
entry concludes with the writer stating
my odds are slim but it's all I can
think to do I must outrun the Grim we
only have a handful of Clues to try and
piece together what exactly happened
here the tent fire bottles and cups
indicate at least someone reached this
area peacefully did our unknown riter
make it here alone or were they
traveling with companions perhaps in
their state of extreme paranoia they
stumbled upon two other Wizards and
ended up in a fiery battle that left all
of them dead would love to hear your
theories on this one so let me know in
the comments if you have any thoughts on
what exactly happened here our next case
leaves little doubt as to what caused
the death of her victim by traveling
Southwest from the North Ford bog flu
flame and into the forest you should
eventually find a small Stone Shack this
one is up on a higher terrain so it's
probably easier to reach traveling on
your broom than on foot when you locate
the Shack stand at the front door and
walk over to the left side until you see
a tree with some yellow flowers there's
also a shovel near the base there you'll
find the body of a man crumpled over
with his hands over his ears his letter
is from a witch named tasmina and in it
she provides our unknown victim with a
few pointers on how to become an animus
now at first I actually thought this was
a cruel joke and that tasmina had
intentionally settled to murder this guy
but these instructions actually do match
what's on wizardingworld.com for
becoming an animus unfortunately for our
victim it appears that he missed tasmina
postcript
P.S don't forget cotton for your ears
even though mandres are handled by
students at Hogwarts as early as their
second year they're typically working
with younger mandres whose screams
aren't yet fatal for fully grown adult
mandres however their cries can be fatal
to anyone who hears them without
protection if there was any doubt at all
about this Wizard's cause of death the
three mandres just behind him can
actually be picked up and added to your
character's inventory if you've flown
anywhere near the East Hogs meat Valley
flu flame you may have noticed a few
different pumpkin patches in the area
our next victim rests in one of these
fields as you make your way closer to
the body you'll see a rather large burn
mark on the ground as well as bits of
pumpkins scattered about the area
clearly there's been some kind of
explosion that's taken the life of our
downed victim the letter beside him
which somehow managed to survive the
explosion is written to from someone
who appears to be a friend named jokasta
Callum and jokasta are both fans of
little pranks but it's seems Callum may
have pushed too far with an old squib
and a jinxed toilet jokasta thinks the
squib is aware of Callum and his pranks
and that he'll do anything he can to
stop him she specifically warns that the
squib may have tampered with tools in
Callum shed so is the individual before
us Callum who died after a squib
tampered with his tools taking a closer
look at the scene we find what looks to
be three fireworks which I would wager
were the source of the explosion there's
also a small Satchel holding a few
unknown liquids I went over to the
nearby shed and while I found a few
tools on the outside the shed itself was
empty and I didn't see any other Clues
to help us piece together what exactly
happened here so while I'm not sure of
the specifics it would seem that jasta
was right about the squib maybe he
rigged the fields with explosives and
set them to detonate when he knew Callum
would be working now it's also important
to remember that although squibs were
incapable of magic themselves they were
still aware of the magical world they
could see things like ghosts and
Dementors as well as places magically
hidden from Muggles like Hogwarts Argus
Phil a known Squid from Harry Potter's
day was even capable of using magical
objects such as the secrecy sensor in
Harry Potter and the halfblood prince so
even though this case involves a squib
we can't immediately roll out magic
somehow having an impact on callum's
death our victim in case number 10 is
the muggleborn I mentioned at the start
of the video traveled to the clag more
Castle flu flame on the south side of
the map from there head north on your
broom in search of a treasure Vault
you'll know you're getting close when
you pass a small brick structure on your
left you'll see two small caves but the
one we're looking for here is the second
one down a bit lower and closer to the
water inside you'll find the victim with
the one-word note and while this one
doesn't have many Clues other than the
Moss and the letter itself it seems
highly probable that this person was
murdered by radical pure blood
Wizards next we have another unknown
victim who died in perhaps the most
gruesome fashion of everyone on this
list today spiders why couldn't it be
follow the butterflies this one is also
found in the forest near the North Ford
bog flu flame if you zoom into your map
you'll be able to see the spider's nest
and the body we're looking for is just
slightly to the right here in these
ruins you may have to clear out a few
spiders first but once you do you'll
find a wizard wrapped tightly in a web
and while the state of the victim leaves
no doubt as to how he died the letter
beside him only raises more questions
the phrase follow the spiders is
repeated nearly 40 times there's no name
nor date was this note actually written
by victim or was it written by another
who was trying to lead this unfortunate
wizard to someone or something something
tells me we've yet to find all of the
secrets contained within hogwart's
Legacy while there were 11 bodies I
found in this search each containing a
note giving a hint as to how they died
there were more bodies I found with no
note at all there are other notes
leading to stories of missing persons
and Unsolved Mysteries but perhaps we'll
cover those in a future video as always
thank you all so much for watching
watching I'll talk to you again
soon